welcome back to cbs this morning in our
series vaccinating america
we look at who will be next to get the
coronavirus vaccine
the cdc recommends the next two rounds
include older adults
essential frontline workers and then
other essential workers
some doctors say wealthy patients have
offered to
buy their way to the front of the
vaccine line adriana diaz looks at the
debate over
who should get the shot
every day that it's not offered to them
is
another day that they're putting their
lives in undue harm
anthony mcgee says who gets vaccinated
next is
personal for him mcgee who works for the
union that represents chicago
corrections officers
says he's seen the virus take the lives
of five guards
and sicken 700 more why do you think
that corrections officers in particular
should go before
police officers or teachers there's
additional risk
that your typical police officer
who arrests someone and then they're
done with them
our people here have to sit with them
day in and day out on a regular basis
a cdc study found that of all
occupations corrections officers are
most exposed to covet 19.
we strongly believe that our members
should be considered
in the early stages he's not alone
groups around the country
are jockeying for position among them
bankers
uber drivers aviation workers even zoo
keepers
the cdc recommends the next round of
vaccine distribution
called group 1b includes those 75 and
older
and roughly 30 million front line
essential workers
like teachers and first responders
behind them
group 1c people 65 and older those with
high risk conditions
and around 57 million other essential
workers
but how to define those essential
workers and the order in which they're
chosen
is determined by each state the kaiser
family foundation found that as of last
week
30 states were still developing more
specific criteria for the next phases of
distribution
richard morocco is the president of new
york's hotel trades council
his union is lobbying state officials to
prioritize hotel employees the hotel
industry has
transformed during this pandemic housing
individuals traveling from out of state
who are considered to be high risk but
also because
hotels have converted to alternate uses
alternate uses like housing coveted
positive patients
there have been some reports of higher
net worth people
trying to pay for the vaccine have you
experienced
any of that oh yes absolutely dr
essen ali is in private practice in
beverly hills
many of his patients are celebrities he
says several dozen people have offered
to pay him to cut in line for the
vaccine it's not
ethical to be offering money to get the
vaccine
people are just used to being able to
get their way when they have privilege
and wealth
dr eileen marty is an infectious disease
specialist at florida international
university
every step of the way of getting the
proper amount on the proper people who
are most at risk
vaccinated eases everything for our
society
becomes closer and closer for us being
able to go back to normal
a normal that will no doubt be new but
that can't come soon enough
for cbs this morning adriana diaz
chicago
you know it's surprising to me we're in
the third category of essential workers
and at first i felt really guilty and
then i think about how many people we
interact with and
and you kind of take a breath with
people paying for it or thinking they
can
pay to get it you're like wealthy people
would try to game the system when we're
trying
to vaccinate our grandparents those in
need essential workers uh it's really
terrible
um and i hope it doesn't happen it
really is up to the states to make sure
that it's fairly distributed yeah
yeah absolutely definitely want to get
it i'm happy being on their lockdown
jerica i'm happy
i know you i will let everybody go
because i've been doing you're very
passionate about it i
am we respect that thank you